there are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products from
august to test for ourselves i've been
seeing these gorgeous hollow glosses
from queen cosmetics all over tick-tock
of course i had to get three of them
these glosses are just as beautiful in
person they honestly feel fine on the
lips as long as you don't apply too much
i packed on this electric shade and it
did feel a little gritty so i recommend
only doing one to two thin layers to
avoid that but these are so cool they
look good on their own but even better
over lipstick especially darker colors
this is the new fenty beauty ease
droplet all-over glow enhancer it can be
worn on its own to reduce the look of
pores or mix into foundation for some
added glow using this on its own i
honestly wasn't very impressed i don't
think my pores were necessarily blurred
and i felt like my skin didn't look that
glowy it kind of just looked like i
applied moisturizer
i think this worked better when mixed
into a foundation i mixed it with my
eavesdrop blurring skin tint which i
love and i noticed it gave my skin a
nice little glow this skin tint is more
on the matte side so i do like that the
glow enhancer made it more dewy however
i don't think it's such a big difference
that i can justify buying this product
it kind of just feels like an extra step
that doesn't add much item beauty is
addison rey's beauty brand people rave
about it slip oils so i figured i'd test
it out with a couple of other products
too so this is the lip quip moisturizing
lip oil let me start out by saying it
smells amazing kind of peachy the color
was actually a little more pigmented
than i expected for a lip oil but i
thought it was so pretty the formula is
on the thicker side it feels super
nourishing and just makes your lips look
so juicy so i am really into this this
is going in my bag next i tried the
boost juice dual ended lash primer and
colored mascara so you can use this as a
lash primer or colored mascara the lilac
side is for volume and the blue side is
for lengthening i have to admit i much
prefer the blue side as just a colored
mascara i feel like once i applied
regular mascara on top of it my lashes
just kind of lump together the lilac
side barely showed up on my lashes but
it worked much better as a lash primer i
also tried the blush and like cream
blush it's supposed to be a cream to
powder formula but it just kind of feels
like a powder i used my sponge to apply
it at first but it just kind of looked a
little splotchy it worked much better
with a brush you can also apply it to
the lips and it was honestly cute it's
buildable which i like but i don't feel
like this is anything special colourpop
drops new stuff like every other day but
these graphics ink liners caught my eye
i really like this tip it's super sharp
and flexible i am horrible at doing any
kind of liner situation so i was really
glad that this tip kind of did the work
for me
however the color payoff on these is not
great i found myself layering up the
product for full color payoff and with
this formula the more you layer the more
textured it looks
it sucks because these are colors that i
don't really see a lot of in eyeliner
but this formula is just not my favorite
it cosmetics just dropped another love
is the foundation brush i think it drops
one of these a year i have one from a
previous year that i really love but
they're actually not the same this new
one is less dense and more flexible than
my old one and i also feel like the
bristles on this new one are longer i
used it to apply my foundation and i was
really happy with how fast it blended
everything in without looking streaky
it also worked great with my concealer i
didn't lose any coverage with this brush
because it didn't absorb the product i
think i actually like this new one
better than my old one i tried a couple
of products from jcat beauty let's talk
about this blush first this color is so
pretty it's like an orangey pink with a
bunch of gold shimmer in it so you get
this very buildable color with some
added glow i can definitely see this
color working for so many different skin
tones the mood flick hollow sparkle lip
balm is one of those color changing lip
products i honestly thought these would
be more glittery but i think it just
looked metallic on me they do actually
feel pretty moisturizing on the lips i
was really surprised at how much these
stain when i was trying to take it off
my lips were bright pink i don't know if
i'd ever use these again but they're
cute i haven't reviewed a too faced
product in forever but it just released
this born this way ethereal light
smoothing concealer and i heard really
good things about it it's supposed to be
super hydrating and smoothing i did not
like the applicator on this not because
of the shape but because it doesn't pick
up product that well this formula is
actually really nice even after blending
it out and setting it with powder you
can still see that luminosity in the
concealer i don't know if it did much
smoothing but i like the coverage it
gave me and how easy it was to work with
this is the dior rouge dior forever
transfer proof lipstick not a liquid
lipstick a regular lipstick so you apply
this like any other lipstick wait three
minutes for the color to set and you
should be left with a long wearing
transfer proof lip i think this
particular shade was a bit patchy but i
evened it out as much as i could i could
not believe how well this worked i was
expecting a lot of transfer because this
is a regular lipstick but the transfer
was pretty minimal it also didn't feel
too drying on the lips i think this
formula is really cool and i want to try
out some other shades
[Music]